you've mentioned
that you love movies and tv shows
let's uh ask an easy question but you
have to be definitively
objectively conclusive what's your top
three movies of all time
so you're asking me to be definitive and
to be conclusive that's a little hard
i'm gonna tell you why
it's very simple it's because uh movies
is too broad of a category
i gotta pick sub genres but i will tell
you that of those genres
i'll pick one or two from from each of
the daughters and i'll get us to three
except i'm going to cheat
so my favorite comedy of all times which
probably my favorite movie of all time
is his girl friday
which is probably a movie that you've
not ever heard of but it's based on a
play called the front page
from i don't know early 1900s
and the movie is a fantastic film
what's the story what's this independent
film no no what are we talking about
this is one this is one of
the movies that would have been very
popular screwball comedy you ever seen
moonlighting the tv show
you know what i'm talking about so
you've seen these shows where there's a
man and a woman
and they clearly are in love with one
another and they're constantly fighting
and always talking over each other
banter banter banter banter banter this
was the movie that started all that as
far as as i'm concerned
it's very much of its time so it's uh i
don't know it must have come out
sometime between 1934 and 1939 i'm not
sure exactly when
the movie itself came out uh it's black
and white um
it's it's just a fantastic film it's
hilarious so it's mostly conversation
uh not entirely but mostly mostly just a
lot of back and forth there's a story
there
someone's on death row and they're um
they're uh newspapermen including her
they're all newspapermen
uh they were divorced the editor the
publisher i guess
and uh the reporter they were divorced
um but you know they clearly he's
thinking trying to get back together
and there's this whole other thing
that's going on but none of that matters
the plot doesn't matter yeah
it's just a matter of play in
conversation it's fantastic and uh
i just love everything about the
conversation because at the end of the
day sort of narrative and conversation
are the sort of things that drive me and
so i really
i really like that movie for that reason
similarly
i'm now going to cheat and i'm going to
give you two movies as one um and
they're crouching tiger hidden dragon
and john wick both relatively modern
john wick of course one two or three
one uh it gets increasingly i love them
all for different reasons and
increasingly more ridiculous kind of
like loving alien and aliens
despite the fact they're two completely
different movies but the reason i put
couching
uh crouching tiger hidden dragon and
john wick together is because i actually
think they're the same movie or what i
like about them yeah the same
movie which is both of them create a
world
that you're coming in the middle of and
they don't explain it to you
but the story is done so well that you
pick it up so anyone who's seen john
wick you know you have these little
coins
and they're headed out and there are
these rules and apparently every single
person in new york city is an assassin
um there's like two people who come
through who aren't but otherwise they
are but there's this complicated world
and everyone knows each other they don't
sit down and explain it to you but you
figure it out crouching
tiger hidden dragon is a lot like that
you get the feeling that this is chapter
nine of a ten part story
and you've missed the first eight
chapters and they're not going to
explain it to you but there's this sort
of rich world behind you so you get
pulled in anyway like
you get pulled in anyway so it's just
excellent storytelling in both cases
and very very different i'll see you
like the outfit i assume the john wick
outfit
oh yeah of course of course yes i think
yeah all right
and so that's that's number two and then
but sorry to pause on that
martial arts you have a long list of
hobbies like it
scrolls off the page but i didn't see
martial arts is one of them
i do not do martial arts but i certainly
watch it oh i appreciate it very much oh
we could talk about every jackie chan
movie ever made okay
and i would be i would be on board with
that shower too like that kind of
the comedy of his cop yes yes by the way
my favorite
jackie chan movie would be drunken
master ii
known in the states usually as legend of
the drunken master
actually drunken master the first one is
the first kung fu movie i ever saw but i
did not know that
the first jackie chan movie the first
one ever that i saw i remember
but i had no idea what is this that's
what it was and i didn't know that was
jackie chan that was like his first
major movie yeah
um i was a kid it was down in the 70s i
only
later rediscovered that that was
actually and he creates his own martial
art by
by drinking was he actually drinking or
was uh
or was he play drinking you mean
as an actor or another
no he was 70s or whatever he was
definitely drinking and
uh he uh in the end he drinks industrial
grade alcohol
ah yeah yeah and has a one of the most
fantastic fights ever in that
that subgenre anyway that's my favorite
one of his movies but i'll tell you the
last movie
um there's actually a movie called
nothing but a man
which is the 1960s uh starred um
ivan dixon who you'll know from
uh hogan's heroes and abby lincoln
it's just a really small little drama
it's a beautiful story
but my favorite scenes i'm cheating my
favorite uh
one of my favorite movies just for the
ending is the godfather
i think the last scene of that is just
fantastic it's the whole movie all
summarized in just
eight nine seconds godfather part one
part one how does it
end i don't think you can you need to
worry about spoilers if you haven't seen
the godfather spoiler alert the uh
it ends with uh the wife coming to
michael
and he says just this once i'll let you
ask me my business and she asks him if
he did this terrible thing and he looks
her in the eye and he lies and he says
no and she says thank you and she she
walks out the door
and you see her you see him
as she's going you see him go she's here
going to the door and all these people
are coming in
and they're kissing michael's hands and
godfather
and then the camera switches perspective
so instead of looking at him
you're looking at her and the door
closes in her face and that's the end of
the movie and that it's the whole movie
right there do you see parallels between
that and your position as dean and
georgia tech chrome that's just kidding
a trick question
sometimes certainly the door gets closed
you